senate democrats pressing forward on  voting rights bills starting the debate  today the legislation would establish  national early voting and vote by mail  standards which are already in fact here  in our state democrats say the bills  would make the ballot more accessible to  voters but republicans disagree  this is about one party  wanting the power  to unilaterally  rewrite  the rule book  of american elections  democrats huddled this evening to  discuss the next steps with a procedural  vote planned as soon as tomorrow but  republicans are expected to block it  from getting the required 60 votes in  the evenly divided senate